good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday you are
over the hump we are happy to report
hey claude how are you doing
hello jacqueline i am doing so good i
feel like every day on this podcast you
could probably hear it in my voice from
like our monday episode to our tuesday
we didn't have an episode monday sorry
our tuesday episode to our wednesday
episode to our thursday i am getting
better recovering from my trip
recovering from my rash recovering from
pretty much everything i picked up on my
journey to mexico austin and back
um and i think i should just start the
episode
really strong and give everyone a rash
update we need a rash update
and i know how like everyone's like
waiting with baited breath to see how my
irritated patch of skin
is healing so i will show you
no but what's the diagnosis because you
have like terms and you have facts yes
so i went to the doctor yesterday and he
said it's because i was like coming in
there with my webmd i'm like i have
cellulitis it's not even webmd it's
toast md
literally and he's like i actually don't
think you have cellulitis it's not this
right texture and it's not changing
shape um but there's probably just like
bacteria from the venom stuck in your
arm he did give me an antibiotic because
if you if you wait too long and it is
cellulitis like it can actually be
really serious like you can lose your
arm
so it's venomitis
it's venomitis but i am on a steroid and
a um antibiotic just in case it is
cellulitis and i kind of just preach for
how much i love steroid packs because
you know my general malaise from the
trip like i had lost my voice a little
bit i'm 24 hours on my steroid and like
i'm already feeling back to basics you
know are you voided out
oh i'm writing so hard like especially
in the morning when i take those first
couple pills i get like like i'm on
speed like i talk so fast and so much
and like i can't focus my eyes that's
just what we need a write it out claudia
no it's it's been a while since i've
been write it out headline claudia's on
roids
tell a friend
she's on voids and her song comes out
tomorrow and she hasn't even spoken
about it as much as she should and also
i think point three is important and
will then we'll get to the song which is
that claudia does not have cellulitis
tell a friend
yeah tell a friend it's not cellulitis
but i really want to thank everyone who
reached out to me like panicked in the
dms because cellulitis can be really
serious and i had never even heard of it
so if i hadn't even
seen those dms like i probably wouldn't
have gone to the doctor i would have
been like oh it's fine and you'd just be
living with venom and then you would
turn into a bee
so here is the update on the actual
patch
the bump has gone down completely it's
just like discolored and it's not that
itchy anymore so hopefully by tomorrow's
episode i'll be like free and clear but
we'll see you never know where
cellulitis can take you you never know
and what we do know though is that your
song is coming out tomorrow in what is
maybe like the
the
shortest lead up to anything that you've
ever done
you're dropping a song on us tomorrow
i'm dropping a song on you guys tomorrow
if you follow me on tik tok like you did
get a sneak peek of the chorus last week
and if you follow me on instagram you
got a sneak peek of the pre-chorus today
so it's called a hundred percent
obviously it's gonna be available
midnight tonight on all your streaming
platforms it's gonna be kind of the
cornerstone of my tour which picks back
up on thursday and then we're going like
hot for four months so i just feel like
it would be incumbent upon every single
person listening to this podcast to
familiarize yourself with this song
because like it will be the song of the
year and i'm not even like joking
yeah i've listened to it a number of
times now and it really gets stuck in
your head so just watch out for that and
i just have one thing to say
we've got power sweet and sour
sweet and sour thank you that's a lyric
from the second verse that i think
everyone will really really be connected
to
there's power in those words like it's
beautiful no the song is really so good
they're sour in those words
this song is so good and so fun and just
like another anthemic moment from our
queen
thank you so much and you know the last
time our song came out we did a
performance
on um our podcast which is probably one
of our most iconic toast moments if you
haven't seen that familiarize yourself
with it it's on youtube um but now that
we're virtual like i have to figure
something out it actually might be
easier for me to perform my song
virtually on the toast on maybe tomorrow
or monday like you could pre-record and
we could add it to the episode
we're gonna figure something out yeah i
think that would really add a special
touch
yeah so stream it spotify apple muse
everywhere thank you very very exciting
i can't wait new music friday
new music friday we also just have a
great episode it's thursday and there
was i caught up on everything i finished
cheer i watched euphoria last night was
the real housewives of orange county so
there's a bunch of tv recap in addition
to just like the world turning
once again as it always does
as it always does a little update for me
on the hobbies front i got so huge i got
so many great suggestions from so many
people yesterday about hobbies really
there it seemed like there was like ten
of like these are the hobbies that we're
all doing which is like paint by numbers
i ordered a paint by numbers um paint
paper
have you heard of paint by diamonds is
that the one with the wax it's the one
with rhinestones i don't want yeah and
you put it on with wax i've seen it on
tick-tock it looks like you're gonna
like that i didn't order it it didn't
that's not was not tickling my fancy but
i ordered some like brain workbooks i
ordered a calligraphy set and a a
starter kit like to teach me how to do
calligraphy i feel like that's cool yeah
that
would it's like something that i think i
would excel at
and the piano has made it into the
apartment and by piano i mean keyboard
um the keyboard is here practice starts
today i ordered piano books that will be
here you know in the next few days you
learn my song
oh my god but in the meantime i can like
get piano sheet music on my ipad and
play like that so i think
i'm really i have a lot
that is you know in front of me and i
think between all of those things i will
find something that i love to occupy me
for the next few weeks
that's amazing and you know you said
something on your instagram story that i
really just wanted to echo because a lot
of people suggested puzzles and i've
been telling you
for years that like puzzles are so you
you have such a keen eye you're very
smart in like a unique way and i just
think you would love puzzles and then
when someone suggested it to you you
were like i'm down but i don't think
that like the current state of my body
is um conducive to doing puzzles and i
have to say you're a hundred percent
right like as a non-pregnant person who
does puzzles it's back-breaking work
i think unless you have some sort of
like special puzzle table but you know
what like my dining table would actually
be like a decent puzzle table it's a
good height it's a good height there's a
bench but still like i could just my
lower back aches thinking about it
don't take the chance it's not worth it
okay i mean if all of the other things
fail maybe i will
go the puzzle route but that's just
where i was at currently but i will give
it a shot at some point in my life
because i agree
it seems like it would play to my
strengths
a hundred percent
100
percent don't let them forget go hard
till the end cause you know that we are
um also i got a lot of feedback on tick
tock when i teased my song people were
like this doesn't sound like claudia
well guess what it is me and there's way
less auto tune on this song than there
was on my previous one so you can't win
it is me [ __ ] off
i find the beginning of the song to be
like extremely seductive
it's very sexy it's like the perfect
date night you want to get pregnant play
that song
yeah it's very sexy and seductive and i
think you guys it's it's definitely
you know new territory for you
yeah and i think it's it's really a song
for everyone and what was your sum of
your inspiration when you were writing
this
and perfect um
i would say my inspiration when writing
it was watching the person who wrote it
and that was really inspiring for me as
a writer
i did love honesty
of course no my friend felipe who wrote
toast also wrote 100
you know and as always it was
collaborative but like i would never say
that like i personally wrote the
majority of the song like i had a few
edits a few notes but i didn't write the
song yeah
and then what was the second question
um and performing it like where where
were you sourcing inspiration from
that's a really good question because
actually this song in particular is in a
different key than toast and it's a key
like i'm not 100 comfortable with i
actually have a very low voice and most
pop popular pop songs are in a much
higher key
and so at times when i was singing it
like i definitely felt like i was
screaming
but and i was like very unsure of it and
i was like to my producer curtis i'm
like i don't think this is gonna work
and he was like just trust the process
trust the process and when i heard the
first cut i was like oh man this
actually sounds so good
great i think it sounds really good too
i'm excited for the audience's feedback
and you have to start a 100 challenge on
tick tock
i know okay so somebody last time this
really really cute toaster made a
sickening dance to toast and i don't
know if she's still a toaster you never
know these days but if she is like
please we loved your work the first time
or if anyone who's like a big tick tock
dancer wants to make up a dance i will
totally do it i just like i'm more of a
dancer not a choreographer okay i mean
you can't be everything singer
you performer and i've tried
dj
dj that was rough that was but now
you're making the music but it led me to
this place
no regrets
it's also like crazy ass snowing in new
york today so if you're out and about
stay safe and if you're ordering in food
don't be a dick like whenever it's
snowing or raining like really crazy
like tip well and if you can't then
don't order because it's treacherous out
there yeah it is treacherous but it's a
nice cozy day on the inside it's
definitely a reading day or a piano day
for me it's a catching up on sex in the
city day so i could talk about it on the
podcast tomorrow i've been seeing some
headlines about sex in the city about
like what the plots are and it seems
really
bad i mean are you talking about miranda
and chang
no i'm talking about one i
[Laughter]
seen this yet and maybe it's a spoiler
for you but i'm i'm just so don't say it
just please let me say it because
literally don't say really relevant
tomorrow it's really literally tomorrow
you could say okay could i you're always
getting on my ass about spoilers okay
i'm gonna just tease it and let me know
if you've seen this that miranda starts
reading a book
quit like a woman yes and that's the
book you were literally just talking
about yes okay okay that's all i wanted
to say
yeah miranda is spoiler alert
when i'm
having i've already seen it having a
problem with drinking yeah and this book
quit like a woman we were talking about
on the podcast because i added it to my
want to read shelf because it's called
like the radical choice to stop drinking
in a culture obsessed with alcohol and i
literally got an email to my email
because jackie's the only person i
follow on goodreads that jackie
wants to read this book and i'm like
girl are you okay
it still looks really good and i
probably am going to read it just when
i'm pregnant like it's not like a
radical choice to stop drinking the
choice
there's nothing radical about it also
speaking of books really quickly i just
want to congratulate the redheads
because we had 50 000 instagram
followers i saw and i just think that's
like the biggest deal i think so too and
it's just such a special amazing
community we absolutely love doing the
podcast we love the books and like uh
you know to commit to a podcast it's a
big deal in itself but to commit to a
podcast that also requires you to read a
book it's like a lot of homework so just
to know
that the communities out there is strong
and that you guys are loving what we're
doing and we're loving doing it it just
it felt really good
you know you put that screenshot on your
instagram and i'm like oh my god that
looks like reese like it looks like a
real book club i know and my goal for
redheads like i'm just going to manifest
something if i say
is like not i mean obviously this will
never happen like everywhere but like in
and if you own like a local bookstore
hit me up but like to have like a
redheads table in the bookstore where
it's like these are the redheads choices
you know like reese has that
oprah
you know what we should have done
because not to like take your promotion
and turn it into mine but my paperback
book does come out next week available
for pre-order on amazon and i'm doing a
live event with barnes and noble get
your tickets you get a signed book with
your 25 ticket um and this new printed
paperback has new york times bestseller
on it which i was like really proud of
and we should have put on the back a
redhead's choice like how dumb are we oh
yeah we could have put that like circle
that would have been like the first the
first one we're so dumb that would have
been so cute yeah that's like that's big
ting's dreams but um barnes and noble
tings to have like a table that says
like the redheads choices with all the
books that we've chosen that are
available that's really cute that's like
a
goal yeah even if it happens at just
like one local bookstore if you you know
are just working the front desk and you
want to you know get a folding table and
take some initiative to get a folding
table organize the books take a picture
and put them away
we'll make a graphic for you a hundred
per one
we need a button now when we're back in
studio like how we have all of our sound
buttons we need to add a sound button
whenever we're like agreeing with one
another hardcore 100
don't let them forget go hard till the
end cause you know that's
so good
so so good okay so those are all of my
updates
for today mazel tov on 50k it's a really
big deal and you're just well on your
way to becoming like
ricio
riccio a girl can dream
yeah she can
so i guess without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
spritz society at this point if you're a
toaster and you haven't tried spritz yet
you are not living spritz society is the
most premium the most delicious
sparkling cocktail you'll ever have as
you guys know it is our family business
you guys have been loving it we've been
loving it it's gonna be in store soon
it's all available
to order online direct to your house um
it's made with real ingredients real
wine real flavors and it comes in four
fabulous flavors so the wine is 100 real
it is super premium white wine harvested
from california grapes and there's over
a bottle of wine in every four pack of
spritz the flavors are made with real
fruit flavored so that's real grapefruit
real pineapple real blood orange and
lemon and the ingredients are only a max
of six ingredients in every can of
spritz that's wine carbonated water cane
sugar citric acid natural flavors and
the actual fruit itself i don't know how
many canned cocktails you could say that
about six ingredients and you can
pronounce every single one of them it's
six percent abv tastes delicious so you
know it'll get you where you need to go
with that six percent
you can order today start making moments
with spritz and you can buy one pack you
can buy a variety pack which is where
you can try each of the flavors or you
can scribe subscribe every month to make
sure that your fridge is always fully
stocked head over to
spritzsociety.com that's
spritzsociety.com
[Music]
order today and of course use code toast
for 10 off your order life is too short
for drinks you don't love so choose to
drink spritz
damn straight
damn straight in today's episode is also
brought to you by sunbasket who's ready
to feel amazing this year i mean i'm on
my my roids i'm already feeling amazing
and thanks to sunbasket who delivers
healthy meals you aren't on the hook to
shop and cook to hit your own health
goals
and it turns out you're probably much
better at eating fancy food than you are
at cooking it and that has never been
more true for someone like me who didn't
realize her oven in her apartment didn't
work for the first two years that she
lived here
sunbasket delivers the joy of eating
with bold flavor flavors organic produce
and sustainable seafood and meats their
award-winning chefs are constantly
innovating with new recipes and global
tastes to keep it interesting each week
with dozens of options sunbath baskets
fresh and ready meals are perfect hot
lunch hack heat and eat in minutes so
that works for me in particular some gal
on the go they've got healthy snacks
grab-and-go breakfast items for busy
mornings whether you eat vegetarian
paleo gluten free low carb high protein
whatever it is some basket has something
to check any and every box you can
choose from recipes like pan seared
salmon honey balsamic lace chicken
chipotle barbecue tofu salad jackie
you're a vegetarian queen
you could set up weekly delivery you can
skip weeks when you need to it's simple
and easy and you will love it your
family will love it you love it at work
when it's just like not the day for you
to run out and get a salad
trust and believe sunbasket will make
your life so much easier and they're
also offering ninety dollars off and a
free gift when you order
when you go to sunbasket.comtoast
and enter the promo code toast.checkout
that's sunbasket.comtoast
promo code toast
thank you claudia
our first story a little royal news
queen elizabeth is facing a hard choice
in the prince harry security debate she
won't go against the government a royal
expert says so we'd say that again
prince harry is in a debate with the
british government because they will not
provide security for him
when he comes to the uk
well he's not a royal right queenie vibe
is trying to stay out of it but she's in
a tricky spot according to weekly
um
and they're coming for what prince
phillips memorial right yes
tbd if they're coming i think it's like
based on the security question so can
they bring their own security
yeah they have the means you know they
want free government-funded security oh
girl come on
come on no no i mean you're not royal
like that's literally when you decided
to take a step back which was totally
the right decision for you and your
family that's exactly what you gave up
like and you were able to then go to
america make more money than you
probably would have ever made as a royal
and be able to afford your own security
i'm sorry i'm siding with the government
on this one and that's something you
will never hear me say no i agree they
gave up so many of the um
like the burdens of being royal and they
also gave up some of the privileges and
that's just how it is you can't just
like not want to do the unfabulous
things and then also want free security
so a royal expert a royal expert you
know take that with a grain of salt
exclusively totally
no kristen continue exclusive but this
sounds you know
true
exclusively told us weekly that it's
hard for the queen as a grandmother to
not really be able to intervene she's
not going to go up against the
government and say well you know you
need to give him security because right
now the metropolitan police are saying
they've conducted a review and concluded
that the threat is considered low to him
this makes it one of those situations
where the queen is always going to
choose being the monarch at the end of
the day right over being a grandmother
over being grand
which i think makes sense i mean i'm
sure she's come up against the i mean we
see it in the crown all the time like
margaret wants to marry this person the
government says she can't like queenie
has to go with the government like she
is ahead of government technically and
you know what it's not like the
government's decision is wrong i think
like if she were asked
what she agreed with she would agree
with the government like they're not
being unreasonable you're not royal
anymore right but i'm sure also a part
of her just wants
harry and megan to like come and be in
the fold and like be happy with the
family
well to be honest it's like low-key
annoying of them just like
if they want to come like it sounds like
they do
because they're wanting security like
they want to come
it would be uh you know a step in the
right direction with i know him and his
brother aren't speaking like just pay
for the security like to them how much
could it be out of their millions and
millions of dollars like what a couple
hundred grand yeah
i agree just pay for the sick just pay
for it if you really do want to go
unless this is like you know well we
were coming but then we wouldn't get
security so it's like they looked like
they wanted to come but they didn't
actually want to come which is something
i would do like could be that you can't
send me you can't send me a private jet
i guess i'm not coming also they could
like just stick close to the family and
you know piggyback off of their security
yeah but then they have to be like close
with the family and there's a lot of
drama still
you know what's so interesting is like
and i've learned this during the oprah
interview too and it seems to be ringing
true it's like so much of these like
issues within the royal family have to
do especially when it comes to harry and
megan have to do with security
like what
like when they were talking to oprah it
was just so many of the issues were like
well we didn't feel safe because we
didn't have security it's like
security's such a big part of the family
dynamic weirdly
yeah
yeah i mean i i think it's a big part of
their lives in general
yeah
um about i'm sorry harry megan are wrong
for this one unless they just don't want
to go which i totally understand that i
could see happening but i do hope that
they go
because sam i'm ready for uh
if there's a reconciliation
about like you know reconciling with the
family and if they're not just stop
talking about them then
right no and that's fine so here for a
reconciliation and me as well
like families are meant to stick
together through thick and thin yes
so we'll see what happens there
i don't know up soon probably are you
ready for our next story
i am yes ma'am
lena dunham wants to make an older wiser
version of girls
which enough we've been through enough
with you lena nobody asked for
hbo sex and the city inspired series
girls went off the air in 2017 and
writer starlina dunham is already open
to reviving it the 35 year old discussed
the major possibility of rebooting the
show with the hollywood reporter she
said i look back and just like the sheer
goal of me stepping onto that first day
24 year old me landing and standing in
silver cup studios the old sex and the
city studios she um is saying let's do
this and that the recent
sex and the city revival could pave the
way for girls to return
to the small screen please no i'm
telling you girls could never return to
the small screen for one reason and
that's because lena dunham like
overnight went from being like the most
beloved belle of hollywood to being the
most hated woman in america and i'm not
sure if it's because of that really
weird [ __ ] she wrote in her book or that
article she wrote who said it my jewish
boyfriend or my dog um
i think it was just us that were upset
about that yeah no totally but like the
world went from thinking lena dunham was
the greatest feminist who ever lived to
literally thinking like she was an evil
monster so i think it would be an
enormous mistake
for hbo to and like when you go back and
watch that show like i know i watched it
and like i was living for it at the time
but if i were to go back and watch that
show i would be like what the [ __ ] am i
watching it loki wasn't good i mean it
had good moments
that i think really captured people but
overall yeah it was like
so insane
yeah and it got more insane as the
seasons went on
right because it was supposed to be like
this actual realistic version like
insects in the city they all had their
own apartments like it was a real you
know accurate retelling of what it's
like to be like a post-grad millennial
living in new york after you just left
college like your parents cut you off
and for that i think that's what got a
lot of people connected to the show
because
they were all living the same reality
and then slowly but surely like that
grip on reality they had just completely
went away completely
so
i don't think that there's a need for
this a time for it
a want a desire
i think and i think like lena dunn if
she wants to come back to the small
screen like give us something fresh and
new and
we'll see how it goes
yeah or not or not of course or not it's
always good to just like stay home i
love to stay home
but girl with no job i think girls we're
good on girls i'm all set thank you so
much yeah
are you ready for our next story it's a
little ben news a little exciting news
for ben a new email he said i thought
you were saying ben is in the news no
yeah i know it's that's what it sounded
like sorry i just can't read the story
without thinking about ben because this
is my crazy husband getting into now
nothing a new emo festival is reuniting
all of your favorite acts it's called
when we were young it's taking the
internet by storm it's going down with
some of the most iconic acts in emo and
pump pop punk music of the last two
decades including my chemical romance
paramore dashboard confessional jimmy
world bright eyes take back sunday the
used alkaline trio and afi to name a few
expected to appear ever levine at the
one day only showcase at the la festival
grounds in nevada on october 22nd
so there has been like two major
reactions to the story the first was
like holy [ __ ] like all the emos that i
follow like ben jack vanek aaron gilfoy
like they are quaking they can't believe
la da
and i was very much there too because i
saw boys like girls on the lineup and
like i don't know if you know this about
me but like much of my middle school
years were defined by that one album
from boys like girls again if i listen
to it right now i'd probably know all
the words like it's so good like i spent
a whole summer listening to that album
so i was really excited and of course
ben was excited so he was like can we go
and i was like i mean we could say we
will but we know we won't
then the second reaction is people are
like how are every single one of these
acts gonna perform on a one day
festival this is fire festival this is
astro world like people are doubting
majorly because i've never seen a line
up that big for a one day festival
i didn't even think about that the
bandwidth and also or you know
even say it's not fire festival but it
means that like you have to choose
between some of your favorite acts if
they're going on simultaneously also i'm
seeing here that we the kings is
performing which is just so exciting
three oh three
yet do you remember oh three of course
so okay that i hadn't even thought about
that i do feel like this is too much for
one day but i also feel like vegas has a
lot of the um it's not fire festival
because they have the infrastructure in
place
to handle like mass amounts of people
but if i'm ben like i'm excited and i'm
overwhelmed
nervous yeah so it's true like do you
have to miss paramore to see ever levine
like how does it work how does it work i
feel like you guys should go
well this was also a big week for the
emo community because paramore announced
like they're back in the studio making
music and they haven't made music in
years
um so that was just like a good time to
be an emo kid like i would go but i do
feel overwhelmed like i can't lie well
then ben should go because this is like
i feel like i need a whole spreadsheet
like i would need a crazy ass
spreadsheet with a map and color
coordinated tabs to figure out where to
go what time to wake up who to miss who
to see like
i'm tired no but usually these festivals
like have apps that give you exactly
that where you like build your schedule
yeah you say like who you want to go see
and they put it on a schedule for you
and with like what uh stage it's at and
there's usually a map if it's a well
done festival there's usually an app
well this is backed by live nation but
so is astroworld so
you really never know
and and i think it's something in the
culture because i'm feeling it too like
i'm just generally now skeptical of
festivals especially new ones
yeah
i i think that's fair to say i think
fire festival definitely you know put
that fear in every one of and astroworld
yeah but for different reasons
for different reasons
yeah
like firefighters before fire safety
before fire festival no it was like
never even thought that like you could
buy tickets to a festival that's being
put on
and it just like doesn't happen and it's
just like sandwiches in a tent on a
beach
yeah you were bamboozled yeah so
they're different but still eventually
it becomes an issue of safety but for
different reasons yeah that's true
are you ready for our next story some
exciting news
only if it's the exciting news that's
brought to you by single drunk female
is it yeah yeah yeah oh my god thank god
okay samantha fink is a person in
progress and being a person is hard
single drunk female is a new free-form
original series coming to hulu this
january it's from the executive producer
of girls and the executive producer of
russian doll samantha used to get drunk
all the time but now she's getting clean
and that's gonna get real messy fresh
out of rehab samantha is forced to move
back home and live with mom who she
affectionately calls her smother she's
working at her local grocery store
taking naps in the cereal aisle and
going to meetings sam's sobriety one day
at a time but the days just keep on
coming
with her former drinking buddy and newly
found friends of the program by her side
sam is trying to make the most of her
second chance a chance to start over a
chance to be a slightly better person a
chance at love because when you start at
rock bottom the only way to go is up
check out the new dramedy that is sure
to make you laugh even it's sometimes
it's just to keep you from crying single
drunk female series premieres thursday
january 20th on freeform and it's
streaming on hulu so that is today you
guys don't miss it
thank you claudia and our next story is
some really exciting relationship news
from one of our favorite people lady
mary crawley
michelle dockery the actress who plays
lady mary is engaged to
phoebe wallerbridge's brother jasper
what
yep they've been together since 2019 and
news of their nuptials was announced in
the times this week and they are engaged
that is so cute
so cute i i feel like i never see
british yeah i i mean i don't actually i
don't know because i don't know anybody
is
i don't know her wait phoebe waller
bridge oh that's not phoebe bridger's
don't ask me questions phoebe waller
bridge okay it's from
uh
the show on amazon flee bag
about a bug yeah fleabag and she is
british and so her brother is definitely
british and that is actually cute i
thought i was thinking of phoebe
bridgers
the singer yep don't know either of them
i'm so sorry to report
that's like honestly like phoebe
bridger's is like a gen z thing and i
only really figured her out because i'm
on tick tock okay good i'm glad that
someone has a brief knowledge
but we never see people from downton in
the news they're so to themselves
yeah and i'm just so happy for lady mary
i really never thought about like her
personal life i remember after i watched
downton the first time i went to her
instagram and saw that she's like so
high fashion and just like a darling of
like being is she yeah she's like super
serious like the way that she dresses or
like its styles for magazine shoots or
red carpets she's like very
um
fashion girly
what's her real name michelle dockery
i was gonna search mary crawley
i'm gonna follow her like that sounds
like a like a delicious
person to follow she
her picture she gives me um
kristen stewart vibes
yeah
like similar seriousness
so now she's engaged also i found out
the craziest thing yesterday about you
know like it's on the same level of tom
mom's gams playing
yeah mr darcy
uh-huh
the woman from ted rebecca the one who's
a singer
wait hold on the singer from from ted
lasso sorry ted lasso oh johanna
hannah she rebecca on ted lasso you know
her because she
sings sometimes
yeah she is also the same woman who
played the shame woman in game of
thrones
you're lying like the nun the nun who
was like walking down the street with
cersei
shame
shame
that is actually life-changing
information
it was shocking that woman was so evil
life-changing
how she could be shame and also like you
were telling me ted last was like this
great funny lighthearted show like
that's shocking shocking shocking stuff
shocking yeah so i just thought everyone
needed to know that i don't know if
everyone already put that together and i
was just not watching ted lasso when
everyone figured it out probably it was
it was a shocking moment for me
there are a few moments like that that
like you learn things that like people
already knew and it like changes your
life like when i found out that brexit
was a conjunction of british exit i
swear to god i lost my mind
yeah no it's like we're always pushing
for stuff like that to happen like for
people to join words together and just
like call it and then it was and there
it was happening all around you
that was also like when i found out that
the word martian is like for people who
live on mars like residents of mars
which obviously like would be but i just
thought it was like all extraterrestrial
yeah i'm just gonna wipe this out to all
marvin the martian
literally
wait that's a great segue into our fifth
and final story which is it about
clueless no it's space news
okay space news that like
i want to be you know on the frontier of
the future of space travel like i want
to be into this but this seems
unnecessary let me know what you think
okay
a new film studio will build will be
built in space by 2024 variety this is
from variety
well is it to put together like oscar
contenders or like films of like we get
to see what's happening on mars
i don't know i feel like it's like
andrew bullock up there yeah no like uh
i don't know if it's gonna be like a hub
where they shoot space movies
here's the thing like
it has to be it has to be a studio where
they like capture footage of what's
going on so they can study it not to
make like you know country strong's in
space listen to the deets and then you
can let me know what you think space
entertainment enterprise s-e-e the
company co-producing tom cruise's
upcoming space movie plan to launch a
sports arena and a production studio in
zero gravity se has unveiled plans to
build a space station module that
contains a sports and entertainment
arena who are they filling it with
martians as well as it really has
scientology written all over it as well
as a content studio by december 2024 a
podcast studio named se1 the module is
intended to host films television music
and sports events as well as artists
producers and creatives who want to make
content in the low orbit microgravity
environment the facilities will enable
development production recording
broadcasting and live streaming of
content
we could do the toast from the toast
i thought this was a dumb idea until now
we're talking
no i mean talk about like such
unnecessary money being spent this is so
unnecessary
and or if it's necessary someone please
explain to me like what this is going to
do for a society it's like do you want
to go record our podcast today like at
the studio down the street or the one
downtown
the one in space like what is the
difference is the audio better and to be
honest
there's no ambulances in space that's
true
there's no construction
i just don't think like we are at the
level of space like education and
knowledge
for this like this seems like something
we might do in a hundred years you know
yeah not by 2024 and i also just feel
like things aren't really like
i wouldn't say perfect on earth on the
ground
that we need to now be taking our
talents to space
well you know what if it means getting
away from all this nonsense going on
around me like maybe it's not such a bad
idea you could use some space
yeah
i could use some space yeah so let us
know if um we're being hard on you know
the future we're not we're not and if
we're being like anti-future
no we are not like we are forward
thinking like queens we fully
embrace the new but this is dumb
yeah dumb unnecessary nobody asked for
it there's enough studios producing
enough content that nobody wants to see
right here on earth
right here at the morning toast
no people want to see it
100 in 1080p you guys we got 1080p
yesterday wasn't it tell us how you did
it i've been following your like journey
to get our videos from home in 1080p but
i haven't asked you how you are doing
that so it took a few
days because first we were recording in
1080p then i didn't realize i have to
also export in 1080p and then actually
and keep exporting in 1080p i just
thought because the files were in 1080p
eventually it would just be 1080p so at
every step along the way i ensured we
were intending to take longer it took
longer but the quality was chef's kiss
so uh also if you're watching on youtube
make sure that when you're watching our
video you're you just press the little
settings and make sure you're watching
in high quality picture not like the
automatic it automatically will put in
like 320.
yeah so
we're evolving every day here at the new
interface
and soon we're going to space
cool
can't wait
i'm ready i would do the first podcast
from space
of course but if they would give it to
like joe rogan but it should be given to
us oh no it should be given to joe rogan
because he's like obsessed with
extra terrestrial like yeah he's really
big into like ufos and
i think he would appreciate it more and
he had elon on his podcast so like he
has access oh yeah i'm sure like they
already offered i'm sure if he wanted to
go to space tomorrow and podcast he
could he has all that i wonder if his
spotify contract will let him do it
yeah but um he's like really into all
that stuff so he deserves it more than
us because i watched that uh
what was that documentary we watched
that ben made us watch about aliens yeah
uh paranormal
yes
and it was fine but it didn't like
change my life yeah i actually like hate
space and i don't care and
how do you feel about alien activity
sorry that's what i meant i think like
space exploration is important and what
nasa is doing is great but like these
people who are like area 51 aliens like
extraterrest don't care got it it's
possible i'm not saying i don't believe
but like i have my own problems like i
don't need to worry about other
creatures on other planets like i have
enough going on
very fair
now let's get into the tv recap we have
so much to recap
okay so the tv recap is brought to you
by away suitcases which is one of our
favorite brands of all time and i just
got back from mexico with all of my away
products away is a modern lifestyle
brand that creates thoughtful products
for every traveler for every kind of
trip they started with the perfect
suitcase which we both have multiple
ones
they're crafted with features that make
travel way more seamless and now when
travel looks so much more different than
ever before you can always count on a
ways range of suitcases bags and
accessories wherever you take your next
trip
whether you just go to the corner store
a weekend away an extended stay with
friends or family we're all navigating
the current reality of travel but no
matter your destination or your style
the away suitcases bags and accessories
all come in a variety of colors sizes
materials to suit your needs and inspire
your future travels so if you are a
queen who hates checking bags you have
to get the standard away bag it is the
biggest most perfect size bag to fit
into the overhead bin space and you'll
get the most storage inside your bag so
that's just basics then i graduated and
i got the big one for like big checked
abroad trips and i've never had more
crap put in a bag in my life and the
away they just think of everything like
each bag comes with its own matching
laundry bag so like remember how we're
always talking about like what to do
with your dirty undies when you go on
trips away has thought of that maybe
they were listening to the morning toast
because they give you a laundry bag and
it give you like this little sponge it's
almost like a magic eraser that you can
use on the outside of your bag if like
tsa scuffs it up which they and all the
little scratches come right out they do
yeah they do yeah they also have a tsa
approved combination lock to keep all
your belongings safe and the lock is
right on the bag it's not like an
external lock that you're obviously
going to lose right also they have a
size because i always figure like if i'm
not if i'm
checking luggage i'm going to bring the
biggest suitcase i have but sometimes
like you don't need all that space their
medium size is actually the perfect
size for when you need more than a
checked than a overhead bin bag but you
don't need to bring a bag that's going
to last you two weeks
super easy to roll through the airport
with the 360 degree spinner wheels
really smooth the all the products from
away are designed to last a lifetime and
so if any part of your suitcase breaks
their standout customer service team
will arrange to have it fixed or
replaced there's a 100-day trial on
everything that they make so you can
take it out on the road live with it
travel with it get lost with it and if
you decide it's not for you you can
return any non-personalized item for a
full refund during that period
and they offer free shippings and
returns within the us uk europe and
canada so start your 100-day trial and
shop the entire away lineup of travel
essentials including their best-selling
suitcases at awaytravel.com toast that's
awaytravel.com
toast
great okay real housewives should we
recap first real housewives of orange
county because the rest is you know um
evergreen
okay so uh and this one
this should be short because nothing
[ __ ] happened
so this trip looks like nice but really
torturous like i'm i'm not trying to be
a brat but like this house isn't that
nice and everyone's like i just expected
more from heather
oh i thought the house was so nice i
really like how everybody has um space
and privacy i feel like that's really
conducive to like just good mental
health on a trip like for me personally
as opposed to just like being up each
other's asses and like not having a
moment of reprieve especially while
you're filming a tv show so i thought
the house setup was actually really
great i mean all the pools like how fun
does that look but this i don't know
this decor was just and it's like an
indoor outdoor house and it's 95 degrees
and there's like nowhere to escape all
the windows are like open and there's no
doors the heat
is a lot what month is it
i don't know
when
i was loosely trying to figure it out
but i didn't put any i didn't like do
any research
so when heather had the girl sit down
and she was showing them her
architecture blueprints i was like my
god this [ __ ] is so obnoxious but then
when she said like basically she had her
kids late in life and she really wants
to be able to leave her kids a place
that they can all be with their kids and
she was talking about her dream like i
actually thought that was really sweet i
thought it was sweet too like that's
heather though for you because it's like
she's not just like a braggadocious ice
queen like she really like she is
warm
and emo and it's true like her and terry
have like built you know this life and
they have all of this money and it's
like that's really a really nice goal of
something that you want to do with all
of the money that you have
agreed so
i i thought it was interesting i was
wondering if we were going to get to go
to the um see the houses which would
have been obnoxious like if she brought
the girls for that but if it was a solo
endeavor i wouldn't have mind seeing it
so shannon was like actually not
bothering me that much this trip like i
do feel like she's her the best version
of herself like when she's drunk and on
vacation and so she was being funny
and
like i like how her and emily are like
hanging out but like they both obviously
hate each other you know yeah no shannon
is staying low-key under the radar
because she you know she girlboss is too
close close to the sun
heather burned her and now she has to
retreat a little bit she needs to like
get more ammunition she needs to refuel
the troops need to be fed they need
fresh socks and then she's gonna come
back in with her next bout of [ __ ]
but right now she's just in like retreat
mode which
i think is nice it's nice yeah but she's
kind of like irrelevant to the current
storyline because she's waiting for her
next storyline because the last one
didn't go so well do you think it's kind
of dramatic of nicole to not go on the
trip because of noella makes me feel
like there's something more going on
between them because as far as we know
like they're just like having a
weirdness in their friendship like
nicole hung up on noella but like they
haven't like gone into like a blowout so
just seems like a really dramatic thing
to do
yeah and it makes me feel like that's
not the only reason because i also feel
like if heather knew that nicole it's
like nicole or
then she would say to gina no i'm not
inviting noella because then nicole
can't come and nicole is my friend so
but you know what heather might not have
had a choice because noel is a full-time
castmate and nicole is not right i was
just gonna say that too so it's like
nicole's presence is optional
um i would have liked to see her there
because i think i like her so far
and yeah me too
even though everyone's like now saying
she's like heather's um henchman
she is but i don't mind it yeah no
someone's someone's got to do the work
someone's got to do it yeah um also i
just want to like give a major shout out
sorry i feel like i'm writing really
hard this episode and just like talking
a lot and really fast but i'm on roads
so just let me be
um
this episode for me was just like
another
testament
to why long ago i made the decision to
stan emily simpson first of all she's so
funny and like she's so different than
she was like her first season she's
opened up so much more and she's just
like great and she looks amazing in a
bathing suit i've never seen anyone like
look like a like so good in a one piece
and i just love her and for me i just
was like cemented in my statitude for
emily after this episode but i say that
after every episode yeah you do i really
love her as well i really like gina too
i think she just has a good
uh energy energy just a good take on
things generally speaking i mean i wish
she didn't go so hard for noella but
someone had to that was like a
production thing like i don't really
think she cares for noella that much no
and i think that like she likes noel and
noel is going through a hard time so
we're all going to go on this trip
without her like this is noella's new
job like she should just come whatever
can we talk about the passport because
you're telling me like you are so fancy
you have your own jet and you don't know
that to go to mexico you need a passport
and by the way flying private means
nothing you still need a passport so
like she was saying that when she flew
private she could use her passport card
i don't think that's true like i
literally was just in mexico i mean i
hope it's true otherwise what the [ __ ]
was she so dumb i'm telling you i don't
think it's true someone who works in
customs like let us know i don't think
that's true no just like basics the one
thing you need to fly is a passport
she's incredibly
deranged insane she's in she showed up
at the house after missing her flight
and it's like this is disgusting
nobody's here to greet me like you
missed your flight yeah no you missed
your flight you didn't come with the
girls like they didn't even know you
what time you're arriving and then you
arrive and you're like a real hostess
would be there when i got there it's
like we only told shannon so she needs
to sit around all day and wait for you
to come she doesn't even want you on the
trip and she needs to miss it she just
walks around the house talking to
herself like she thinks she's so funny
like she's not she really does like
think that she's doing something and the
thing is like she's so
stunning
and the outfits are sickening and she's
just like comes off the plane in like
the perfect plane outfit then she's
ready for dinner like in the like and i
thought some of the other ladies looks
like they looked like they were all
going in different places and they
looked amazing though um she she did
look amazing but it's it didn't wasn't
giving me like uh
beach mexico vibe it was just like a
nice outfit for a night out in like new
york city in the summer there was no
like bright colors yeah i see you right
so they were all were all over the place
noelle understood the assignment like
shows up so it's hard i feel like it
might be hard for some people to see
when this woman is so fabulous on the
outside that like her behavior if she
was anyone else like the behavior
is
insane
well she acted like a nut at dinner like
with
like well i don't care that heather's
like gina had the best thing like if
you're not gonna eat just like be cool
about it like
like pretend like not making your topic
of conversation being the fact that like
you didn't eat your octopus she was just
being so annoying with the tequila shot
like being so rude like pouring out the
drink when the guy was like can i bring
you some ice like it's a tequila shot
it's gross just drink it like yeah no it
was a lot and i feel like it's hard to i
mean watching the episode it's like yeah
this doesn't seem like a fun dinner
anymore but i feel like the energy
if you were there is like even worse
than what we were able to understand
from watching on tv like she i think she
just like came in sucked out all the
oxygen from the room like made i think
they were having a good time before and
like vibing and as a viewer it's just
like oh she didn't eat her food and
she's like complaining about her shot
like what's the big deal but i think
she's just like someone who just like
sucks all the energy out of her room the
minute she arrives yeah because this
group is like actually pretty good
together like jen is growing on me
they're all vibing in like a nice way
like i actually think jen is really
similar to heather in like their very
calm
sometimes boring vibes so they really
connect but then heather can also be
really fun and that's why she connects
with gina and emily like i think that
the group is like near perfect without
noella there's she just like doesn't fit
in especially because it's heather's
trip heather's everything and they're at
odds
yeah and she like doesn't understand why
that matters that her and heather are at
odds and like
right it she's just like coming in out
of nowhere so we also got a really good
trailer mid-season trailer for what's
coming up this trip to aspen looks
moronic uh
dr jen's husband ryan leaves her yeah
now when i saw that then it makes all
the last few episodes like make sense
where she's like always complaining
about ryan i just think they're wrong
like one of them has to work and then
he's like mean that she's not home so
you go to work [ __ ] what do you think
this house on the beach is gonna pay for
itself no i don't know what i'm gonna
see in the next few episodes i just know
i'm not going to be team ryan
no jen has her head on straight like she
definitely has mom guilt but like she
has to work like what are we supposed to
do just not work that's not how the
world works yeah
yeah so he was pissing me off and now
that i know he's like leaving i'm fully
on board like hating him yeah and i
think that it will raise jen stock
because when her family scenes were like
making me not like her because like her
husband and now no shirt and the dog in
his armpit all the time like leave us
alone
jen on her own i'm
we're good no and now i know why we've
seen like so many weird scenes of her
and her family like they were giving us
some context oh man bruno looks so cute
sleeping behind you yeah no he's
sleeping on heating pad
he does this every day while i record
but you couldn't but he's usually not in
frame you moved back today i did i moved
back today because like my big fat face
was just taking up the youtube screen
and i actually got i got um an email
from youtube and they were like your
face is too big and too close and you've
gotta move back they said dear the
morning toes you two hookers are so ugly
and not funny get the [ __ ] off our
platform we don't want to deal with your
[ __ ] anymore but if you can't stop
yourselves the least you can do is scoot
back just move back
and give us more brew have a good day
literally that's what they said to me
oh wait you know what i think theo's
done with his grooming check oh grab him
or just like dude
no it's okay i'll see him later no don't
get him i think maybe for tomorrow's
friday episode we'll bring the
boys okay we'll bring in the boys
we them boys we making noise
speaking of chairs speaking of making
noise
um cheer okay i finished i apologize
that it took me like two extra days but
my god what okay i want to say baseline
i like the show like nothing bad against
i like the beat
i like the beat
but
we need to talk about how first of all
the show is so long the episodes are so
long because every single scene is in
slow motion and they like didn't have a
lot of content this year and it felt
really stretched out like i saw a couple
scenes that i had already seen once
before like they were choppy with their
editing like
it could have been five episodes but
like they just had to dramatize it so
much and it was just such slo-mo like
it was just a lot
yeah it was a lot i will say it was cool
that they got to bring the cameras to
daytona
because when you're watching the
performances i felt like i was watching
bring it on like the way that they
edited those performances like last year
they loved it they didn't let the crew
in and it was just filmed from people's
phones
and we just had to make do but like it
literally felt like bring it on
it was so exciting to watch all of the
like stunts like close up far away it
was really cool well nca would be
incredibly stupid not to embrace the
filming now seeing as how what this show
has done for cheer like cheers always
had like a big audience like like really
niche fans but now it's like a worldwide
stage and they would just be dumb not to
embrace that yeah and they the
cheerleading like i don't know how it
works over there the cheerleading
illuminati came off pretty bad in the
first season yeah so i feel like by just
like letting them in and not deal like
not making a stink or anything like now
i feel like they're coming off in a
better light and not being so like
uh tyrannical
agreed and so major spoiler
for anyone who hasn't watched just like
turn off now
navarro lost
and i was shocked i mean
it's funny because tvcc like beat them
at their own game like they hired their
photographer they copied all of like the
attitude like they copied oh what did i
say photographer
that too
um well they did now they were on the
netflix show um
so they really like beat them at their
own game because tvcc didn't do anything
outwardly original they just copied what
navarro did and did it better but i do
think we should talk about like why we
think navarro didn't win like because
there was a lot of like underlying like
plots like is the fame getting to them
and i do want to say like i actually
don't think it is i think they all
remained relatively humble based on
remember those few months after the show
like you couldn't get arrested they were
so [ __ ] famous so i think based on
that they were
really not that you know egotistical but
i do think and it pains me to say this
like monica going on dancing with the
stars and missing the first semester
like and leaving them with kali peppers
who is a good coach but who's literally
like two years out of college like i
didn't think that was a good idea i
don't at first when i saw it i was like
and i was watching this i was like at
what point does monica go on dancing
with the stars how is this going to work
with cheer and then when she explained
that she watches every single season
like this is like her biggest dream and
she's doing everything for the kids all
the time her whole life is dedicated to
these kids and then like i think that
she spends so much of her like personal
time like with them thinking about them
and she's right she did something for
herself like once i realized that like
that has been a dream of hers her whole
life and this is a show that she's
always watched i was like i was so glad
that she went and it was first semester
which is when they're not working on
stuff for um
nca you know it's just really like
getting the team together so definitely
they missed some team building stuff and
i'm sure it wasn't ideal to be with
kaylee but i also think that you know
someone like ladarius who could have
used that as an opportunity to like step
up and like show the team how to bond
and stuff is so and my thoughts on dairy
ladarius were so conflicting when we
first saw him again so
there's so many dif this is such a
roller coaster of sounds of sounds but
when we first saw everyone after
cheer season one drops this is before
kovid and we're seeing how everyone is
handling the fame and ladarius comes on
and he's like i don't care about the
fame like he
i was like oh my gosh ladarius has just
become like this wonderful person like
all of them amazing attributes about him
from the first season it seems like he
saw himself and then he's going to focus
on those attributes i was like is
ladarius the mvp
spoiler alert the vote the quote
so i just felt like his attitude the
first seas the first semester like when
monica was gone and in her absence like
really just sunk the team even further
and also by the time they do go to nca
in to daytona in 2021
the fame of it all and the
arc of the show's success like it has
completely dropped like now they're in
it feels like a curse
and you know that like cheerleading is
really superstitious jackie totally it's
like this like netflix curse and it's
also just like the price of fame in
general and when they first got so
famous like they could do no wrong they
had every opportunity and it's like
only the good only the good and then
like you really see even if though it
takes time like uh what goes up must
come down and down it makes me feel like
if they could do it all over again like
they wouldn't have done maybe some of
them would have like i think
you know
for morgan and gabby like this is
everything but i fee i honestly i think
for monica
yes she's feeling so low for like over a
year
obviously i'm sure she's happy for the
success of her kids
but like her cheerleaders yeah but i
think that if she could do it all again
i'd she would think long and hard
i agree and you know at first when they
were like cutting to tv cc i'm like [ __ ]
this like i'm navarro strong but then
the more we got to know those kids like
actually i wouldn't mind having two
separate shows like because the weenies
d like that i thought their whole
background was so interesting like
learning about gyms like flip city that
like
just started to keep kids out of trouble
and then literally ended up sending kids
like the olympics and worlds like i
thought that was so cool and then angel
who like we didn't even get enough of
but it was apparently like the
greatest tumbler who ever lived like
there was more there and i thought those
kids i really liked jada i thought a lot
of them were really interesting but
going back and forth between navarro and
tvcc was like conflicting for me
emotionally because i like stan navarro
but tbcc and vontae like
i was feeling it i was feeling it too i
really liked vontae as a coach his
approach is really different than
monica's at so many different points
throughout the
season i was like
tvcc is going to win navarro is going to
win and when like tvcc hit their first
full out like at 0 like no mistakes and
navarro's was a cluster i was like oh
[ __ ] and then
when they
go to daytona
or no their last full out it's the
opposite this keeps happening like in
the show and then the first performance
then tvcc messes up and then in the
second one navarro messes up and it's
just like gabby no not gabby jill jill
oh my god i love her though
i can't say it's her fault because i
loved her so much
but it is her fault and i'm just happy
for like some of the other navarro girls
who were in the background season one
who like now are getting like instagram
followers and stuff because like that's
a really odd dynamic like netflix came
here they spoke to all of us they only
want some of us and now we are going to
have more followers more business
opportunities than we'll ever know like
then yeah
then one person will ever have in a
lifetime and you just have to you know
hold my feet [ __ ] off
yeah no i agree they must be odd i
definitely think
the
the way like the impact that the show
had on society
made it weird at navarro for a multitude
of reasons
i think especially you know early 2020
but by the time like they're ready to
compete again i do think some of those
dynamics have been ironed out because at
that point it's only gabby who's there
and gabby's always been a celebrity
cheerleader yes
so like the oh yeah no and i think when
i started to realize that tvcc was gonna
win was like they were highlighting so
many of their
cheerleaders who were like the best at
what they do like we had the three
weenies we had jada we had angel and
then i was thinking i'm like who is the
star like we have gabby and maddie like
that's it yeah yeah
i agree there were times i was like oh
tvcc like especially with their tumblers
the weenies i was there was no
competition
but then in the prelims when dee one of
the weenies like fell i was like well
you know what he hasn't had like the
best attitude the whole time like he's
just so good at what he does he's not
like you know smiling oh you know i
actually thought that conversation about
like straight men in cheerleading was
really interesting because
you know we're always used to seeing the
girls who are like
yeah and like i actually never thought
to look at the boys and when i looked at
navarro
you know you thought of like ladarius
and jerry and like they're all just very
comfortable in their sexuality and like
they don't feel weird smiling but then
there's like that you know toxic
straight vibe where it's like i'm not
gonna smile and perform like that's gay
and i thought it was interesting that
they spoke about it because i had
wondered about it as well yeah it was an
interesting take on it and i wonder if
that's something that happens in like
just cheerleading in general because
like the smiles and the all of the
animation it's cringy it's and it's a
lot for anyone let alone someone who's
like completely not into it but i think
like one of the best arcs of a character
like in television history i know what
you're going to say is d like being
anti-face i guess that's what they call
it giving face that's what i'm calling
it then he messes up and he's also like
uh you know
head and shoulders above other tumbler
so like he has this
uh superiority which yeah and like he
just goes out there he does this thing
it feels like nothing to him
then he messes up
and he's like you know has this
crisis like and then when he hits it at
the second performance and he finally
like gives a little something oh my god
i had chicken
slow motion yeah and like you you can
see like how happy he was to hit it
considering the day before he missed it
like i literally had full body chills it
was like my favorite moment ever
and he also edited it he did it in his
way you know yes he didn't be any he
wasn't anyone but himself it was so
beautiful
i agree that editing was like honestly
golden globe worthy like they deserve
all the awards no and obviously that's
just like this is reality so that's how
it happened but the way that his story
wrapped like just warmed my heart
and i loved his mom and his brother
yeah no i loved like how the brother
like went out and figured out all this
stuff for his little brother who he knew
was like more talented than him so like
he went to college and then found out
the best place to go and sent his
brother there like it was just a
gorgeous story like i loved his whole
family yeah no it was it was beautiful
and so i
people i don't know where most people
like landed on who they wanted to win
daytona i didn't have a horse in the
race i felt like both teams deserved it
and whoever you know stuck it best to
deserve to win but it did seem clear
that the judges wanted tbcc to win and
maybe that was just like an fued of
navarro for like putting such a
spotlight on our sport and making us
look like the tyrants that we are pretty
much the whole time i wanted navarro to
win until we met the weenies and then
when it got down to like the last couple
full outs and the actual competition
like
i thought tvcc's
routine was better like it was
it was hard for me to tell because of
all the cutting and pasting stuff you
know
um
so all in all like it was really good
but it was really long
it was really long but it was something
to be a part of you know and we waited
so long i wish they would have
put it out like as it was happening
because it was like the first few
episodes it's like we know what's about
to happen this is not fun that's true
you know
maybe like four here four there but it
was interesting to see like all the like
different like college
like how it's affected college life
kovacs yes
so
like even them having a virtual award
ceremony like that sucked i know but i
was happy for navarro that they didn't
have to cry in public
it would have been so embarrassing it
like sucks for the winners but it's like
very nice for the losers you're saving
face for the losers yeah
um and then the last thing i watched
yesterday was euphoria which was like
kind of a boring episode i don't know if
that's a hot take but just like a lot
happened on the season premiere and this
was episode two and we were just like
like catching up and a lot of it was
like fantasy like imagine if this
happened but i do want to say like i
don't i know you can't answer this
question for me jackie but like does it
make me toxic that the i stan cassie and
nate like so much even though like it's
horrible for a multitude of reasons like
i just really
ship and i think that they would be
beautiful together and that scene of
them like being in love and like her
being pregnant was so cute
oh
i don't think it makes you toxic thank
you
um and then the other thing i wanted to
say and this might be like my hottest
take yet
but the character roo played by zendaya
i think is my least favorite character
she's so self-destructive
and she struggles with addiction like
you have to have a lot of sympathy but
she just
she has like so many good people around
her like this guy she met in na who's
like like like a dad to her almost and
she's just like rude to everyone she's
so rude to her mom like i can't she's
like cheating on jewels who's like the
only person who's ever been nice to her
like
she makes it really hard to be a friend
and i found myself just like not
enjoying her scenes as much as i used to
like the whole show was like narrated by
her but to me it's like now it's about
like maddie and it's about nate like
it's just about other things
interesting that does seem like a hot
take but also as we know sometimes the
protagonist and the narrator is the
least likely character
and then jackie i thought you'll find
this interesting there there's so cause
i saw this on tik tok there's so much
nudity in the show like it's insane
and
the only person who's never nude is
zendaya so she obviously had some sort
of like contract right like i'm not
showing my titties mm-hmm
oh people were talking about it like
where are zendaya's
new to these scenes yeah i think that's
stuff that's like we flesh out common
for protagonists like we never saw flesh
out no pun intended before um like when
you sign on for a show it's like this is
what i am
open but it reminds me of carrie in sex
and city like we saw everyone's boobs we
never saw kyrie's boobs yeah i guess
when you are
top billing that's something that you
can negotiate yeah
and then the last thing i wanted to say
was i was truly quaking when nate
confronted his dad about like the tapes
and [ __ ] jewels and like his history
of cheating on his mom i was quaking
like those cal nate scenes like really
get to me and i figured out who cal
looks like jackie i'm gonna send you a
picture of this person
okay with my phone
over yonder give me a second
okay
because i have a call you guys jackie's
headphones are out i think he looks like
colton old underwood in like 30 years
um
and i think jackie will appreciate that
call because i was like watching him in
the hospital i'm like oh my god okay you
ready i am ready
so i'm gonna text you a picture
to your cell phone jackie
scent okay wait don't open that one it
was the wrong one oh god okay sorry i'm
i'm being moronic
is this as good of a call as hannah and
probably not mr rose
probably not okay open the picture
i didn't get it yet
okay like it's been sent so
three dots there it's there okay
i'm looking tell me
tell me that's not a grown-up colton
underwood
you don't see it
not from this picture but a lot of my
like calls have to do with mannerisms
and expressions and so if he so maybe
you need to start watching euphoria if
yeah if i saw him in action maybe i
would agree but i can't go off of a
picture i'm sorry okay well if you watch
you for you let me know what you think
about that call i don't think i'm
watching he also looks like a
combination actually do you know what
colton underwood's boyfriend looks like
no
well he looks like if colton underwood
and his boyfriend had a baby and the man
was 50 years old that's my call what's
this guy what this guy what's he from
he's from he's giving riverdale he's
giving something what is his actor oh
eric dane uh what's he from i don't know
but that's definitely a familiar name
i feel like he's from something that we
[ __ ] love
yeah burlesque
burlesque oh but he's the rich man who
tries to take quesadillas yes exactly
isn't that just the best feeling when
you scratching it out on your own like
without imdb oh i used imdb but it's a
better feeling when you figure it yes
when you figure it out on your own lady
shackleton
so that is my um
[Music]
final thoughts on euphoria hopefully
this week's episode like something
happens because nothing happened but
it's still like an enjoyable show to
watch even when it's like boring got it
okay cool well thanks for updating us
my song comes out tomorrow do not forget
well it comes out at midnight well
tonight yeah midnight tonight okay i
think i'll be up so
wow crazy i don't think i will i've been
going to bed at like 10 o'clock you go
to sleep so early i go to sleep so late
i know because it's on the weekends i'd
literally go to bed at 6am so i actually
get my sleep on the weekdays
interesting i'm a twisted individual
you're quite twisted okay so i'll be up
i'll celebrate with everyone if you're
not around
cool i'm gonna do my best to stay awake
but it's called 100
spotify itunes streaming everywhere
and that's our
show thank you so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the fast life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so it's spotify itunes stitcher
public radio i have radio cast box all
the places so wherever you listen to
podcast find out some morning chosen
leave a five star view about a beautiful
sunny and smart we are the morning chess
instagram page is still down and we are
still working on it thank you for your
patience we love you have a great day
we'll see you tomorrow for
friday friday
getting down on friday
goodbye